زعيم كوريا الشماليه كيم جونج اون يحض
سلطات بلاده على تسريع الاستعدادات للحرب
الجيش الامريكي يتحدث عن اسقاط طائره
مسيره وصاروخ مضاد للسفن جنوبي البحر
الاحمر اطلقه ما الحوثي
الحوثيون لكن السؤال هذه مزوده بدارات
فاعله تغطي مسافات كبيره جدا كيف
تم اطلاق هذه الصواريخ ولم يتم اسقاطها هل
كانت مفاجاه لانه العمل غير متوقع
المسؤولون الامريكيون يصرحون العثور على
الاهداف الحوثيه اصعب مما كان متوقعا
والمانيا ترسل فرقاطه قادره على رصد الف
هدف في وقت واحد الى البحر الاحمر
النتنياهو يعلن عن اخر مهمه للجيش العبري
قبل ان تنتهي الحرب والاستخبارات
الامريكيه تلاحق كبار قاده الفصائل فما
السبب مجلس الامن يوافق بالاجماع على طلب
دعت اليه الجزائر وعشرات السفن والناقلات
تقطعت بها السبل في مياه جيبوتي خطه
امريكيه مثيره للجدل تربط بين القطاع
والتطبيع السعوديه مع تل ابيب وسعي امريكي
لتوقيع ضمانات امنيه مع كياف وجهاز الامن
الاوكراني يصرح النيتو لن يدخل في مواجهه
عسكريه مباشره مع روسيا بينما بولندا
وحلفائها يرسلون مقاتلتهم لمواجهه طائرات
موسكو
اليمن يستعر
بالضربات الساحه اليمنيه تشتعل بالضربات
الامريكيه البريطانيه مع رد قوي لانصار
الله الحوثييين باستهداف السفن
والبارجة امني وعسكري في صفوف انصار الله
الحوثيين هناك نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
عن مسؤولين امريكيين بان الضربه تدمرت
واضت بنحو 30% من قدره الحوثيين الهجوميه
واضافت الصحيفه ان الضربات باليمن دمرت
نحو 90% من اهدافها لكن الصحيفه اكدت ان
الحوثيين مازالوا لديهم نحو
75% من قدرتهم على اطلاق الصواريخ
والمسيرات وهنا نتصفح
المصدر
[موسيقى]
كما اكدت نيويورك تايمز ايضا ان العثور
على الاهداف الحوثيه اصعب مما كان متوقعا
وكانت قناه الجزيره قد رصدت عشرات سفن شحن
ونقلا عرقه في المياه الاقليميه الجيبوتيه
بعدما تقطعت بها السبل نظرا لعدم قدرتها
على المرور عبر مضيق باب المندب بسبب
الوضع المتوتر في البحر الاحمر وتوقع مصدر
ملاحي ان تستمر فت كره التهديد للسفن
والناقلات عده ايام فيما ذكرت صحيفه فلت
ان المانيا قررت ارسال الفرقه جيسن الى
البحر الاحمر في الاول من فبراير للمساهمه
في اعتراض الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
التي يطلقها الحوثيون وهذه الفرقه تت
مجهزه بصواريخ مضاده للطائرات ونظام
استطلاع راداري قادر على اكتشاف ال000 هدف
في وقت واحد كما يمكنها حمل مروحيات
هجوميه على متنها في الحدود المصريه افادت
صحيفه و ستريت جورنال الامريكيه بان تل
ابيب ابلغت مصر عزمها على شن عمليه عسكريه
للسيطره على المنطقه الفلسطينيه من الحدود
الفلسطينيه المصريه والمعروفه باسم محور
فيلادلفيا خلال ذلك قال نتنياهو انهم لن
ينهوا الحرب بدون اغلاق الثغره في محور
فيلادلفيا والا فان تسريب الاسلحه سيتواصل
وفق تعبيره
ولنتصور
في مجلس الامن شهدت الجلسه التي دعت اليها
الجزائر موقفا موحدا بين اعضاء المجلس على
رفض تهجير الفلسطينيين قصرا وكانت الجزائر
الممثله للمجموعه العربيه قد طالبت في
ختام الجلسه بالبناء على هذا الاجماع
للتحرك قدما لمنع الكيان من تنفيذ مخططات
التهجير فيما كانت مظاهره ضخمه خرجت في تل
ابيب تطالب بانتخابات فوريه مع دخول حرب
القطاع يومها المئه لننتقل الى معارك
القطاع حيث كشفت موقع ولا الاخباري العبري
عن اصابه 4000 جندي باعاقه منذ بدايه
الحرب على القطاع واشار الى تقديرات ترجح
ان هذا العدد سيصل الى نحو 30 الفا فيما
قالت القناه 13 العبريه ان جهاز الامن
العام العبري وجه تحضيرا شديد اللهجه
لرئيس الوزراء النتنياهو من حدوث تصعيد في
الضفه الغربيه في اعقاب البطاله وعدم
تحويل الاموال الى رام الله من جهتها تجمع
وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه اس
سي اي اي معلومات عن كبار قاده الفصائل
ومواقع احتجاز الرهائن في القطاع وتقدمها
لتل ابيب حسب ما نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
عن مسؤولين امريكيين هذا وقدم كبير
مستشاري الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن لشؤون
الشرق الاوسط بيرت ماك جارك خطه مثيره
للجدل تربط بين اعاده اعمار القطاع بعد
الحرب والتطبيع بين تل ابيب والسعوديه
ووفقا لماك جورك ستكون الخطه بمثابه حافز
لاعاده اعمار القطاع الذي ستشارك في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودول خليجيه
اخرى بحسب وسائل اعلام عبريه وبعيدا عن
الشرق الاوسط افادت صحيفه بوليتيكو نقلا
عن مسؤولين اوروبيين بان رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شارل ميشيل اثار غضب زعماء الدول
الاوروبيه بمناقشه خطه استقالته مع الرئيس
الفرنسي امانويل ماكرون فقط واشارت الى
انه ارسل فقط رساله الكترونيه الى الزعماء
الاوروبيين الاخرين الامر الذي تسبب في
غضبهم ضمانات امنيه
جديده الدعم العسكري الذي توقف من جانب
واشنطن للاوكرانيين قد تستبدله واشنطن
بدعم من نوع اخر حيث صرحت السفيره
الامريكيه لدى اوكرانيا بريديج برينك ان
بلادها تسعى لتوقيع اتفاقيه بشان الضمانات
الامنيه مع اوكرانيا مشيره الى ان
المشاورات الثنائيه مع كياف حول هذه
القضيه بدات وفق صحيفه يا فابريس كيا
برافدا الاوكرانيه كما اعلن زعيم حزب
الوطنيين الفرنسيين فلوريان فليبو ان
الولايات المتحده سترفض اي مساعدات اخرى
لكيف بسبب مشاكل تتعلق بحصر الاسلحه
المقدمه لاوكرانيا واضاف فليبو ان الاسلحه
الامريكيه مفقوده في اوكرانيا وهذا يجب ان
يدفع فرنسا ايضا الى التخلي عن دعمها
لنظام كياف ودعونا نتصفح
[موسيقى]
المصدر في المقابل قال العقيد السابق في
جهاز الامن الاوكراني اولي تيكوف في
مقابله مع قناه على اليوتيوب ان النيتو لن
يدخل في مواجهه عسكريه مباشره مع روسيا
لحمايه مصالح اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان الدول
الاعضاء في الناتو لا تستطيع مواجهه روسيا
والقتال ضدها بشكل منفرد ليصرح رئيس وزراء
بولندا السابق ماتيوس مرافيت سكي في
مقابله مع صحيفه الديلي اكسبرس البريطانيه
بان الجيش الروسيه يتمتع بتفوق كبير في
ساحه المعركه وان قوات اوكرانيا التي فشلت
في هجومها ض الصيفي تتحرك في الاتجاه
الخاطئ هنا افاد الخبير العسكري الالماني
كريستيان مولينج لقناه ت دي اف ان القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه ليس لديها اي
احتياطيات متبقيه للقيام باعمال هجوميه
لذا فان الجيش الاوكراني مجبر على البقاء
في موقف دفاعي ليؤكد المحلل السياسي
الاوكراني ديميتري كورين تشوك ان الرئيس
الاوكرانيه فلاديمير زيلينسكي يريد
الاعتراف بضروره التوصل الى هدنه مع روسيا
لكنه متر دد ولا يستطيع القيام بذلك حتى
الان بحسب الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه
ميدانيا افاد اوليكس اوسكان مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني الاسبق ليونيد كوتشما بان
الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه ادت الى تدمير
مدارج الطائره والمجمعات الصناعيه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا وافادت الدفاع
الروسيه في بيانها انه تم تحييد اكثر من
835 عسكريا اوكرانيا خلال 24 ساعه في
مناطق متفرقه من نطاق العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الخاصه وفي بولندا اعلنت القياده
الميدانيه للقوات البولنديه على موقع اكس
للسكان انه تم ارسال مقاتلات تابعه لجيشها
ولل الحلفاء الى منطقه قريبه من الحدود مع
اوكرانيا بسبب النشاط المتزايد للطيران
الروسي